oh you might
do
exhibition matches and all that kind of
stuff right soup wrestling and stuff no
uh i don't think so so here's my thing
with the wrestling matches is like
just for fun if you said hey ben just
for fun yeah would you love to go
wrestle someone yeah i would i would
right i love wrestling i get in there i
love you know i love like so one of my
guys has gotten to be pretty good he's
in he got him kicking a tool he just won
a
junior world title this year
and so when when
i'm doing private lessons i have such
thing about the development of the
athletes sometimes i can wrestle hard
but most of the time it's like i'm just
gonna help them with whatever they need
help with and it's still wrestling and
it's fun but it's helping them you know
for like for keegan kozak this summer
and he's trained for the general title
so to be able to just shake hands
sometimes and say like i'm gonna try to
kick your ass she try to kick my ass you
know like just to go like yeah it's a
good feeling it's so much fun and i
don't get to do that very much so if you
said ben would you love do some matches
and the answer is yeah
the problem unfortunately for me and
maybe you can talk me off the ledge here
is like because of where i've gotten to
my career if i choose to do wrestling
match it's gonna people are gonna be
really excited about it's gonna blow up
and it's like
i just want to wrestle just to wrestle
i'd rather just like go in a room where
no one can watch and just wrestle or
just enjoy it well you could also
wrestle so there's different kinds of
wrestling there's wrestling where
there's an event
and like you know there's a build up and
an announcement yeah and you can also do
like uh khabib style like in the room
there's cameras and you're kind of going
it's like the weeb does that
no in uh marcel did that he woke my ass
a few times yeah exactly i mean i've
seen could be some videos okay it's not
like set up it's just people going hard
and then it's more fun yeah you know and
it's
it's also more like
presenting the beauty of the sport yeah
you know for sure and and like and
there's no winning or losing really in
that context yeah like you're just
you're always joking around a little bit
even when you're going super hard so i
feel like especially in the modern day
with with the internet that's a
compelling way to do so i've thought
about this is the one thing i've thought
about doing because uh i told you about
my buddy was the the content thing it's
called rockfin i thought about doing you
know the old really famous gracie
challenge yeah okay so i thought about
doing the aspirin challenge do you hear
my rule set yeah let's go i'm not sure
i'm gonna do this people are gonna show
up to your like in wisconsin i have to
select you i'll start with a thousand
bucks right right okay 30 minutes you
pin me or i pin you that's it no points
no nothing we just wrestle camera that's
it right it's camera in the room maybe
maybe maybe there's a referee because we
don't want there to be contention for
the pen
so one pin just one pin 30 minutes 30
minutes okay
if i pin you you don't get [ __ ] you go
home right every person i pin it goes up
by a thousand dollars two thousand three
thousand four thousand five thousand and
so on
if you make it the distance and i don't
pin you and you don't pin me i'll pay
for your travel and give you 500 bucks
right just a consolation prize for
showing up
if you pin me you get whatever the
jackpot
is wait who's adding to the jackpot i am
it's my it's my money
but then what's the incentive to keep
winning for you because it's jackpot
well because i'm so i would put the
content somewhere people would watch it
oh you're gonna make money yeah so you'd
make money but it's not exponentially
growing right it's just going up by like
yeah i really think there's probably
only a couple people that could pin me
so i would just not choose those people
or wait till i get a really large
audience and people get really excited
in that case i'm making a lot of money
so
what do you think how many matches would
go with you like call dick shows up i
don't think he could hit me yeah but be
like jordan jordan bros could beat me
but he can't pin me he was never a
pinner yeah he ain't gonna pin me
there's only a few people who have the
skill level to do so right it takes a
lot because so pinning was one of my
specialties i had the fourth most of all
time and i won the penny award the last
two years
um
so and then even down on points and just
pin them this is actually one of the
issues i have with
jiu jitsu and the point system and the
eddie bravo thing i actually think eddie
bravo thinks kind of people get so mad
at me sorry too i think it's [ __ ]
you want me to tell you why it's
[ __ ] yeah so like if jordan brewers
whoops my ass and the score is 16 to 2
but he can't pin me then i get to go to
overtime and get a cradle on him i'm
probably going to pin him
so i'm better than jordan burroughs
nah they ain't right he is what my ass
you know what i'm saying like if we can
go the whole because they do submission
only
so if jordan bros beats me up for was it
eight minutes ten minutes i don't know
what's the length of an eddie bravo
match yeah i don't know that's something
like that yeah yeah
so we go 10 me john bros tonight he's
gonna outscore me significantly but he
he will not pin me i promise you that
okay so now we go we go to the overtime
strong wars but yeah he won't jordan
bros is not going to he's going to beat
me i will give you that kyle jake won't
pin you either no okay okay they'll both
beat me on points very badly now david
taylor he might he might pin me because
he's a very good pin and also
um they'll beat me very badly they will
not pin me um but now we get to overtime
and we get to pick like right so in a
bravo you get a rear naked choke or an
arm bar okay give me a cradle i'll
probably pin him okay a good cradle you
can say cradle or maybe give them
they're not probably not going to pin me
right maybe maybe there's a chance but
probably not because this is another
special day so for people who don't know
the eddie uh eddie bravo thing is uh
when and goes into overtime you get a
dominance position on a person and you
get to yeah basically put them in a
cradle this is the wrestling equivalent
yeah but you uh take their back maybe an
arm bar yeah like a wrestling arm bar
yeah and i don't think that's very fair
because if someone whoops your ass they
whip your ass and then you know and so i
think the reason why jujitsu people
accept that rule set is that i don't
think i think they know this but would
admit it i don't think they're their
point scoring system and include adding
adequately rewards what people value so
like in wrestling we value takedowns
because it gets closer to the pin and
the the most valuable scoring is a near
fault near to the pin because that's the
ultimate goal of the sport whereas in
jiu jitsu for example like if i were to
get a takedown uh so like if i went to
gordon ryan and he just didn't pull
guard i would probably get the takedown
now if somehow he didn't submit me which
he probably would right but say he got
got close to like 12 submissions but
somehow i slipped out of all of them
now i win 2-0 like that's ridiculous
like he should very clearly win because
he almost submitted you know what i'm
saying like
there and i realized the difficulty i
realized the difficulty in rewarding
near submissions but that is the most
valuable thing is getting close to
finishing the match and in most
competitions they don't actually reward
that but okay so this this isn't about
the sport this is about the ben askren
challenge that we're talking about
okay what why 30 minutes why not
unlimited time
why do i go until whenever well because
then it's just a cardio thing because at
some point um
then someone would just have to fall
over dead right there's no more skill
level involved it's just who can stand
up the longest you honestly don't think
30 minutes is a cardio thing too
how do you think that's actually going
to look kyle date going against you for
30 minutes so it's going to be kind of
boring um
for the most part
what position are you going to be
because you well you can but you can't
you just can't have a gigantic amount of
action for 30 minutes so i i relate to
this because some of my kids when when
teaching them wrestling they're like
well
but
i can't do that for seven minutes and
i'm like well you know like say if i had
you do
uh hang cleans at a relatively heavy
weight as hard as you could you're not
gonna last seven minutes you're gonna
your pace will slow down right so my
thing is like well your pace doesn't
have to step here because i'm wrestling
you're competing at someone so if you're
here at 100 and you go to 80 but they go
to 70 that's great and now you go to 60
but they go to 40 yeah this is even
better right because the gap is growing
so we don't necessarily if we get tired
that's fine if they get more tired
that's better so i think most people
would know that so they would
kind of slow it down
um
but yeah i think the third third i mean
i've wrestled 30 minute goes i've
wrestled i've wrestled hour long goes um
you're not gonna get so tired you're
gonna fall over in that time period but
at some point if it's unlimited someone
will get so tired that or dehydrated
that they're just gonna freaking fall
over yeah but you think what about
making it exciting and dynamic
you think the other person is always
going to be going for the pin
and therefore thereby make it dynamic
well if they're working that hard then
they might exhaust themselves right
right and and obviously then if you're
if you're being that dynamic then you're
adding risk to yourself too because you
are you know doing that well i love this
this is a great idea
well i figured i'd rack up like 20 pins
against bums you know or not not as
great people in the beginning and then i
would start bringing in better people
because they would be enticed by you
know twenty thousand dollars the
possibility to win and not not much
fanfare just a camera and just chemical
that's it in my wrestling room yeah yeah
like the gracie challenge yes
yeah
and so then maybe you have like um
you know for most people you have
someone edit like the 90 seconds of the
most fun things that happen and then you
can watch the entire 30 minutes if you
want to yeah i mean i think most people
if they're not really really elite um
i'm probably gonna pin them
if they're not really elite
so yeah but i don't know i i that's
something i've been thinking about this
just been like fun for me to think about
um and obviously it plays in my skill
sets because my cardio is good and my
pinning is good also
so
you